regresar a su campaña aparece el
principal objetivo del presidente de
hace sólo nueve días fue diagnosticado
con kobe 19 pero pretende realizar un
mitin este sábado 10 de octubre en
florida así lo aseguró en una entrevista
con fox news en la que se hicieron
presentes algunos ataques de tos
suscribimos a los médicos hoy creen que
estoy muy bien estoy muy bien quizás lo
sé y se los digo tome el regeneron es
fenomenal
creo que trataré de realizar un wiki el
sábado de la noche
si podemos si tenemos suficiente tiempo
para afirmarlo pero queremos hacer un
mitin en florida probablemente el sábado
en la noche que podríamos hacer otro
pensilvania la noche siguiente el
presidente agregó que hoy se realizará
una nueva prueba al tiempo que desestimó
su valor al señalar que no es necesario
hacerse test todo el tiempo
volver a la escena pública es otra de
las controversiales decisiones del
mandatario desde que resultó positivo no
obstante en un sorpresivo anuncio el
médico personal del jefe de estado
mostró su respaldo el sábado será el
décimo día desde el diagnóstico del
pasado jueves y basada en la trayectoria
de diagnóstico avanzada que el equipo
médico ha estado conduciendo anticipo
por completo el regreso seguro del
presidente a sus compromisos públicos en
ese momento el anuncio se produce el
mismo día que el mandatario informó que
no participaría en un debate virtual
contrario bailén el ex vicepresidente
demócrata respondió que tampoco
participaría ante la negativa de trump y
pidió aplazar el encuentro una semana
[Aplausos]